other one
right goody good morning everybody and
welcome to this joint overview and
scrutiny committee meeting i'm
councillor alistair mccraw
and i'm chairing the meeting today my
apologies for the
late departure of this service i mean
sorry the late arrival of this service
but uh
i'm afraid the trains are running as
normal as in late
uh first of all can i remind you of some
domestic arrangements
please ensure that you maintain social
distance from all other persons
in the chamber and in the social areas
please ensure that you wear a mask
unless you are speaking or
if you are unable to do so and that you
use the hand sanitizer and wipes
provided
please maintain social distance at all
times during the meeting
and during any breaks and ensure that
microphones are turned off
when not in use that you do not
interrupt other speakers
that if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off
additionally we will be using the modern
gov app
for e-voting this this meeting
i'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being filmed
and by entering this meeting as a
speaker you're also consenting to be
recorded
by the council and the possible use of
those images and sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully excluded
um before we get started it looks very
nice to see everybody face to face again
and uh it's been a very strange year all
right mostly face to face at least we
can see the color of our eyes
and we don't have to look at a little
series of boxes and then move around
so that is a great pleasure and it is
really nice to see everybody again
hopefully
we'll see how that works for the
productivity of the meeting
so can i move now to the agenda uh
apologies for absence and substitutions
henriette thank you chair we have
received apologies from councillor gould
you very much and um
declarations of pecuniary and
non-pecuniary interests are there any
such to declare
no such good item three jos 2020
confirmation
of the minutes of the meeting of the
joint overview and scrutiny committee
held on the 22nd of march
2021 are there any points regarding the
accuracy of those minutes
if there are none can i have a proposal
that those minutes be accepted
thank you councillor muller and second
bid by councillor osborne
uh governance officer will now conduct
the electronic vote which will be
on if i can find it on the voting
in modern government
now highlighted in blue four against or
abstain
and then you confirm
counselor
do we have the results of the vote
yes chair that's 10-4 that doesn't add
up with me
sorry ten four ten votes four
who are we are more than there are ten
of us
are they not yes yes that's fine sorry
yes there's
that's great thank you sorry i think you
sounded a little bit
uncertain about it i thought we were
going to do the eurovision all over
again
so the minutes of the meeting of the
22nd of march 2021 have been confirmed
and will be
signed at the next practicable
opportunity which i would imagine
councillor william and myself
will be doing quite a bit of signing of
minutes for the previous year
after this meeting will we not
that's correct yes so that'll be a
session
titan 4 to receive notifications of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme
already report non-received chair
item five questions by the public
non-received chair
and night and six yes it is six
questions by councillors none received
yet
and then finally we come to the
substantive item of today's
meeting which is a
sort of self-generated report um
so i'm just going to run through this
which is a
review of the overview and scrutiny
committee in the year 2020 to 2021
the year just passed now
you have before you i believe a um
the overview and scrutiny report for uh
that year as a guidance there are also
some suggested notes
um as to the themes whereby we could
carry out this review
that's one method quite open to any
changes members can take this any which
way they like because it's been a very
peculiar year
and some of the lessons we may have
learned this year may not be applicable
in future
but then again they may so i think we
have to be
aware of those possibilities since
everything
could be said to be still in some flux
so we are looking basically at the
topics we've covered this year
in all of our overview and scrutiny
committees whether they be joint or
separate
what worked why what
didn't work and why what lessons we
would learn
what recommendations this joint
committee would make
to any future ons committees for babel
mid-suffolk district councils
and uh we'll try and see if we can come
to a summary at the end
um i'm just going to kick
something off right away because i think
it's a good place to have a starting
point
that we were operating last year under
the conditions
of lockdown remotely
and it's an elephant in the room it has
to be addressed what lessons would we
learn
that were good about remote meetings
what were bad about remote meetings and
are there any aspects of remote meetings
that
um we would wish to continue using
i just throw that open as a start
because i think we should get it out of
the way
and then we can get to the substantive
business of actually carrying out
scrutiny over to you members
yes certainly councillor brandon thank
you claire can i just clarify do you
mean
in relation to overview and scrutiny or
the council altogether
i was thinking in particular of the
practicalities of carrying out a
scrutiny function using remote meetings
specifically
but obviously there are some general
points that would apply to all meetings
so i think it's open to you and
effectively
this is just a starting point i'm
suggesting you're welcome to go
elsewhere by the way
thank you chair uh i must admit uh
bearing in mind the circumstances we had
in the last year
i thought the online meetings worked
extremely well obviously it's nice to be
back face to face
but yes i was quite happy with what
happened and how we went about the the
work during the year
so thank you chair councillor william
and the councillor
yeah thank you chair
yeah um i agree with what councilman has
said
um the one thing that i think is missing
when we are
on on zoom is the sort of interaction
and the informal
meeting beforehand and so on i think we
missed we missed that
um and i don't think that can be
replicated on
on zoom but i think i think it went it
went quite well
of course there were one or two one or
two teething problems with some people
who
um dipped in and out of broadband um
i don't know whether that's that it's
possible to um to do anything about that
um i think one one of the things that i
found was
that the the pressures on staff there
were
more pressures on staff as a result of
the way that we were operating
um so i really felt at times i really
felt for staff who were
having to be online
with perhaps their pets or
children around i i think they did
extremely well
but there were there were occasions when
i think one or two felt a little bit
embarrassed because a dog barked or
somebody came to the door and so on but
all in all i think i think everyone
everyone did did really well um
but it's really good to be back seeing
people and and you know just chatting
with people for a few minutes beforehand
albeit
socially distant i think is it it helps
in the
in the sort of running of the meeting if
we
if we've met inform me just beforehand
thank you
just to add to that since my co-chair
has just spoken i think
did you find him i found sharing those
meetings the most challenging
chairmanship i've ever had to undertake
um i don't know if you felt the same way
but it was
it was hard work at times just to keep
control and track of everything with
multiple screens which were necessary
and you know you lose that
ability to have everything in front of
you and you can't certainly face
okay uh so councillor mclaren and then
councillor brandon
thank you chair um i just want to say
um thank you to everybody and that's
officers
and our committees joint committees
i think i actually thought we did
extremely well
certainly for baber we had slightly
different
challenges during the year that
mid-southwark didn't have
where we had additional meetings but i
think they were undertaken
properly and within the procedure and i
think it's all credit to everybody
especially the officers
i think they supported us very well and
the advice we got from
um emily was amazing in some of the
hurdles that we had to
overcome during the the year so i just
want to say thank you
thank you thanks so much uh councillor
brandon
thank you chair yes um i'd like to um
reiterate what council mclaren said i
think we had a lot of help and support
from offices
and i think it did work as well as as as
it could
i certainly found it quite stressful at
the beginning
when my uh from from a technical point
of view
um and and i think all of us had to
learn how to deal with this new way of
working
and you know how lovely it was just now
i just stuck my finger in the air and
caught your eye
and that was that was it
um and you know you almost can't beat
that in in a meeting room
and you know again i think you um
in this room here today we've got that
mix of
the formal and the informal um
there is no atmosphere on an online
meeting
um and you know it's lovely to be back
in person again and i think our meetings
will
while they were functionary before
i think they will improve um by being in
person again
although i think um
while meetings in general not necessary
ons
may going forward it might be a good
idea to have a hybrid
option where possible and if the house
of parliament can do it
i don't know why we can't
but you know i think that'll be a nice
option for those for whom it will be
more practical
um but um i'm pleased to be back
and but thought it worked quite well
once i got over all my technical
problems
thank you thank you councillor brandon
as i understand it
there are um legislation would be
required to ensure or to allow hybrid
meetings that's going to be dealt with
that westminster obviously
we may well have input as from the
council on that subject i believe
that's already underway isn't it emily
thank you
yes councillor casten
thank you very much mr chairman yeah i
can relate to what you're saying about
the um
the workload of the um chair because um
the workload of the for the council is
in the meeting
i had my first meeting in person last
monday
auditing standards and um
i i noticed when i got in that room how
much the workload was reduced
sitting sitting there i think um one
thing on the um
the monday meetings monday morning
seemed to be a very busy time for
broadband
and um you there's quite a lot of lag
with the um
papers and sometimes you were trying to
look on a paper for what someone was
talking about and you couldn't find it
before they'd finish them
talking but i think it is a massive step
forward
and the fantastic thing about it is that
we've proved that we can do it
in a time when we've been forced to do
it and it would have been very hard
to make that shift in normal times in
normal times it would have been a huge
step
and um the it took the pressure off i
think making
being forced to do those um remote
meetings but um
yeah i think there's definitely a future
in it
somehow um the hybrid meeting
seems to me like a a really good way of
reducing the carbon footprint of the
council
re reducing them travel time and
and all that and to give people a choice
but we we have to wait to
see whether we're allowed to and um
that'll be the um
that'll be the interesting thing going
forward whether we're
we're allowed to carry on beyond covered
thank you there were some positives
obviously um
castle cutter
got a button right eventually there we
go
well i think um teams meetings have been
really a
vive accidents and the mishaps have been
a blessing in disguise
for the council in general when you it
is
proving that we are people and even in
the time of crisis when you have
the noise of a dog in her background
when you have a child and a background
interference it brings the humanity back
into the meetings
you can put politics aside you can put
um
the meat in the side just remember that
we are all trying to live
trying to interact in the meeting at the
time of crisis
and doing a blinking good job of it
you know it it was made harder and it
was proved to be harder for officers
but it did bring an appreciation to us
about we might not have had previously
um so i think it's um it's been really
good to have those meetings
um it's also been made
the technology advantages that we had to
make
due to it the in voting
which it's been a blessing it might not
be always be possible to get a
it might not be possible for me to raise
my hand for instance or to get people
some
somebody's uh catch your eye or
something like that so if we had
something as well that i could
click and notify you that i want to
speak
wonderful if we can do that as a hybrid
fix it makes
it makes it more accessible and if we
could have these
hybrid meetings where not just
councillors could um
possibly not be able to attend but
actually attend virtually
but if we had speakers attending
virtually to some meetings outwards
open up it would make it more accessible
make it more
remote but more personal so i think that
uh
if we could make a statement to the
government saying how as even if if
it's not just a council order is it
scrutiny saying
that these remote v remote meetings
these hybrid meetings
are proving to be not just
beneficial but could be crucial to how
they meet how
council should be run then that would be
i think that's what we should be doing
so it could well bring bring better
accountability in democracy um members
of the public can
access and be engaged in the meetings to
a greater extent i have quite a list of
speakers now
i don't have to look for whose hand went
up first anymore but i'm just going for
it
so cancer osborne did you raise your
hand or would i was i misreading that
no you weren't grandin then that's okay
i must have just
i must have just picked up on the wrong
visual cue my apologies
now you did cancel rapping and i've got
you after councillor grandin though
so i had her first cancer grandin
thank you chair and a point was raised
earlier about monday morning meetings
and i did find and i think
others did that because our
overview scrutiny meetings were on
monday morning
um that everyone else is meeting soon to
be on monday morning and there was an
issue with broadband um certainly i
found that and i think others did too
i wonder if we're in the unfortunate
position
of having to work from home again
in the way that we had whether it should
be considered
that monday morning meetings should in
at that time be moved to another
day or time um
is that something we should consider
perhaps it's certainly something we can
consider i think some of it has been
because of uh
well in past room requirements and then
practice and then officer requirements
and so on so if it was diarised
as you know we would hopefully would not
be thrown
immediately into a crisis position
but if it was known that
if you were put into that position um
any meetings on a monday morning would
would be moved to another time
um would would you think that would work
what what is this it's um how long is a
piece of string question every time we
discuss
um you know the times we meet in
previous years i recall we've had
suggestions of meetings at differing
times some prefer
afternoons some prefer mornings those
who've got
working jobs find that sometimes a lot
not convenient for them um
sorry i was thinking more from a
broadband point of view
rather than a convenience point of view
okay
the point we can certainly look at that
i think it's actually still comes down
to officer time of course and the
availability of resources there
um i had council repping on the next
thank you chair um i i i agree with
what um other councillors have said
about the the conduct of the
of these meetings over the past year a
bit and i think
the officers um are to be
commended for the way in which they've
allowed us to
keep our work going uh both in terms of
their personal effort
and and the technology moving us i think
relatively seamlessly from
face-to-face meetings to off online
meetings um
i would strongly suggest that we do
indeed explore
the option of having hybrid meetings
because there are some meetings where
effectively we're not really discussing
matters of import but we're looking at
what's been happening or
what you know looking at agendas going
forward so there are some meetings i
believe that could be
quite happily held online um
and and so we should definitely be
pressing for that i mean it's a way of
working
that is very prevalent now in private
industry and works extremely well and
it's as
for for the good reasons that other
counselors have mentioned in terms of
efficiency of the time and
and not traveling and so forth i think
the other thing that um
as a council we need to uh
put a lot of effort into is um pressing
um
by whatever channels really the the
proper rollout of broadband
in in in suffolk because i think if if
this is going to be the way that we're
going to do things in the future
and i certainly think so then we need to
have ubiquitous broadband
all around um and it's not only just for
us to have
meetings um that you know and we don't
have
disconnections going on and so on and so
forth but i think it will
also help to drive the economy of of the
rural areas in particular
because people then can more happily
work from home because they have a
a reliable connection to to use so
um that there's a couple points i'd like
to make on that
that's an excellent point it occurs to
me as well that should
the committees ever decide they wish to
set up
some form of task and finish group a
small number of members concentrating on
one particular subject
that the team's meeting would be ideal
for that since
no voting would necessarily be required
and it's the voting
element that requires our face-to-face
presence
and correct in that analysis councillor
wellam
chair you said almost exactly what i was
going to say i was going to add a
question
and that is if we did have more task
task and finish groups can can they
actually meet with
without the public having access to the
meeting um
because i'll come on later i think we've
we've not used custom finish groups this
year
but there may be a for all sorts of
reasons but then
that may be the way forward thank you
chair thank you very much council of
wellington i think that moves us on
quite conveniently
to another theme that might be
developing
emily did you want to add something on
this point
yes thank you chair i just wondered if
it would be helpful for members for me
to just
um outline the framework of the high
court decision
um that ruled that the meetings had to
return to in person
and that only applies to formal
decision-making meetings of either the
council the cabinet or the committees
so anything like a task and finish group
or an informal meeting with officers
can still be held virtually also
councillor briefings
training that kind of thing um following
the initial
high court ruling there was a follow-up
question which was around
how is a meeting in public defined
and the high court said that to be held
in public
that meant that members of the public
also had to be able to
attend in person which is why we can't
just rely on the live stream so
all of our meetings are being live
streamed which means members of the
public have the option to view them
but to be truly in public you have to
have provision for members of the public
to attend in person
that part of the ruling also stated that
active participants in the meeting also
had to be able to attend in person
which has kind of prevented the notion
of a hybrid meeting that we've been
discussing
in kind of preparation for returning to
in-person meetings where we thought that
speakers or officers
could perhaps join virtually
unfortunately that's not possible
because
if you are intending to participate in
the meeting you have to be in the
meeting room as well
so a change that does require an
amendment to primary legislation
we are lobbying through our professional
organizations and through the local
government association
to push that forward but it's anybody's
guess how quickly that legislation
would come forward in terms of the
demands on the parliamentary timetable
so hopefully that was just a useful
summary chair it's very useful thank you
emily councillor carter you wanted to
follow up on that
yes it's just an interesting point on
how members of the public
have to be able to attend a part person
we are one of well the only council that
i know of that
actually holds our meetings outside of
our
boundaries outside of the constituency
so for members of public to attend our
meetings actually it's more difficult
less accessible for them to get to
actually attend a meeting
in person than it would be online
whereas
if we do have offices um that are used
uh we have public facing the points
access buildings would it not be
possible to set up remote links to these
buildings
in constituencies in the areas such as
in stone market and sudbury
places for members of public to attend
their local office
and attend a meeting sit down in front
of a camera wouldn't that count as a
a an in-person meeting
um but it may well be possible i think
it's something under active
consideration
rather than dwell too long on the
pluses and minuses of remote meetings
internet teams and all the rest of it
there's one point i'd just like to uh
members to consider as to whether
the use of remote meetings affected the
quality of the work
and the breadth of the work that
overview and scrutiny were able to carry
out
in the course of the last year i think
it's a fair question
and it should be asked so council carter
uh euros okay um any thoughts on that
yes counselor carter please one thing i
do
miss from remote meetings is ability to
mute myself when i'm having a spasm
attack
so that made my
a bit quicker and less interrupted fair
point
and then council mclaren
thank you chair um
interesting the comments being made
about wanting
online meetings and in some ways
i think we're reflecting the fact that
we've come out of a very
long period of something that was stable
different but stable and i think
we are showing some reluctance i think
to come back to probably what we had
before i personally
am glad to be back and i think that
the benefit of interaction
with my colleagues of all parties
um i missed that and i also felt that
you didn't
get a sense over a camera of
people's actual body language
and how it was being said and i think
that is part of the skill
of being sat in a meeting like this and
i
certainly uh perhaps some hybrid
meetings but i i'm just glad to be back
in a real world
thank you you miss the humanity don't
you it's i think it is the visual and
verbal
non-verbal clues and the wrestling
councilor grandin
thank you chair i sometimes i i like
being able to
volunteer to join in the meeting
as i did as i'm doing right now
on a online meeting it becomes much more
formal arise
and sometimes i felt forced
to say something when actually i didn't
have anything
that i wish to say because we were going
round
in in an order or someone had already
said it and
so i didn't really feel that i had
anything to say
whereas um now
i can volunteer to
to uh participate just at the moment i i
wish to participate
not because we're in the rotation
of being off so that everyone can get
fair go
um so i've i'm finding that i
feel more comfortable in participating
in an open room situation
any thoughts on the effect
remote meetings may have had on the
quality and breadths
of the work that we undertook in that
time councillor scoff and then
councillor wellington
thank you chad um well i was going to
say actually i i think
remote meetings particularly large
meetings if you look at
council for example um they were very
lengthy meetings
um partly because of the technology
because we had problems with the voting
app to start off with and
could we get the broad bandwidth and so
on but i think sometimes members were
inhibited
perhaps from making the contribution
that they might have made because they
were conscious of the time
running away in meetings
i don't think that affected the work of
the overview and scrutiny committee
quite so much because it's a smaller
committee
but certainly the larger meetings i
think members
felt perhaps well i won't make a
contribution because we've you know
taken so long
and some of those meetings could take
three or even four hours
um i wondered if we could move on to the
what worked and why
bit um because i had some particular
observations if you'll allow me
um from my experience i think the use of
witnesses worked really well
and i think that's something that worked
well whether we were
online or on or not for example
our review of the citizens advice bureau
i think that was an excellent meeting
we had really good quality information
provided by the witnesses and we're able
to
grill the witnesses if you like for
their views on
the workings of the council and so on
and perhaps to a lesser extent the
outside bodies
because it was mainly members of the two
joint committees who were the witnesses
so we were sort of witnesses to
ourselves which was
uh not not quite so good um
from a vice chair's point of view i
thought the briefings and officers
report preparation
via remote meetings work very well um
and obviously that's something i would
expect we would carry on doing
because it's even though it's quite easy
to get here
from for me by train it adds another
hour onto the day
in terms of the meeting time so i
thought that worked really well
um i thought in terms of the quality of
reports we were obviously
slightly handicapped by the fact that
officers were dealing with
many issues outside of the meeting we
weren't the only thing that was
important in their mind
and they were dealing you know with that
but i thought overall the quality of the
reports
was good and the major reports was good
i don't
think we suffered too much by having uh
to operate under the pandemic situations
i think you know
that they were good and in terms of
adding value finally
i think we added value where we could
although with some of the issues it's
extremely difficult to add much value
because it's more or less a review
of something which is a foregone
conclusion um
but where we did add value i think that
was useful so they were my points on
what worked and why thank you very
useful thank you councillor scarf and
i'm glad we're moving on to the other
themes
i think it's highly likely that chairs
meetings chairs briefings
for all committees might find themselves
being conducted online that would make
sense
um dragging oneself okay not dragging
perhaps but
having to make one's way to endeavour
house for four or five people to meet
just doesn't make sense particularly
when we've all got busy lives so that
might well be
a future practice across the council as
a whole
any other themes from the list in front
of you councillor welland you had
something
thank you chair um yeah i agree with um
everything that councillor scarf has
said there's just one thing from a
personal point of view that
that i have missed in terms of um inter
interaction with officers in the in
in my role as as chair um
i i was i was one of i'm one of the
people who quite often would come into
endeavor house um i didn't i didn't feel
okay it took an hour out of the day but
uh and i would quite often meet
with officers i had not planned
necessarily to meet
um and if they were officers who were
in a preparation stage of a report we
would quite often have
a bit of a dialogue and i missed that
but having said that i think i think
that each of us who wants to have that
dialogue needs to find a way
to have that because we're not going to
come back to a stage where
you can just bump into the planning
officer or
or whoever just by having a cup of
coffee on the
um outside of the office
so i think we've got to find a way to
perhaps
have more one-to-ones or perhaps
the chairs and the planning officer if
it's a planning report or
or um communities office if it's a
community's report
or just to to not to not wait until
we've got
the set meeting when we're going to
expect the draft report but
for us to have a bit of interaction with
with the authors before we reach that
point
you mean the happy accidents that yes
you accidentally bump into somebody and
in fact it results in you moving things
forward
so i think that's something that we've
got to we've got to try to
we've got to plan the unplanned meeting
i think
um the other thing about the
the year that we've had is that
um we've been guided almost entirely
by the needs of cabinet and council
most most of the most of the
issues that we've we've scrutinized have
been
those which we've been asked to do and i
think we've got to
we've got to be braver and we've got to
say we've got to set our own agenda
and in order to do that perhaps
a lot of the background work on some of
these
items which we have to do year by year
perhaps
we could look at a task group
go doing doing the background work
so that we don't spend so much time
going through
you know tables and sums and percentages
and so on
um and if i can just carry on with
something
slightly different i've got a feeling
that
i mean i enjoy join meetings because
they're more of us so we get a much
broader
discussion but joint meetings mean mean
there are field meetings
which obviously which in one way is a
good thing
but it also means that there are fewer
issues scrutinized
because we try to match we try to match
our
agendas it may well be that we should be
looking at
not having so many joint meetings
but for mid suffolk members to think it
to scrutinize mid-suffolk
um issues and and similarly paper
i think you're absolutely correct
councillor willem i think last year was
very much circumstance driven
and not just the kovit 19 but the fact
that
the officer time um because of that and
other things
meant that effectively our agenda was
largely set by those circumstances
and the physical realities and hence the
extra meetings that
we held actually a lot of meetings i
mean there were periods where scrutiny
was
amongst the hardest working committees
on the council i think that's fair to
say
um and looking at the reports which will
be presented to both councils this week
you can see that we actually got through
pretty much
most of what we planned given the
circumstances that in itself
is remarkable councilor carter
i was wondering if it'd be possible for
us to ask the officers in attendance
what it has been like um we were talking
about to be
accidental with a happy accidents and
meeting them
well i for one i'm sure other counselors
have
turned to teams to actually contact the
officers more and speak to the officers
more i rarely came in unless it was for
me and i didn't have those accidents but
i've actually spoken more
in the past year to majority of the
officers when i have
the whole time of being a counsellor
i've enjoyed reaching out i've enjoyed
having a
a joke occasionally on teams um
okay um i've quite possibly irritated
more offices in the past year than i
have in
my time being it as a counsellor
but um i did wonder how has it been like
for
counselors to reach out send your
message and teams had to
receive an email from us has it been
more of a hindrance or has it been
beneficial to
have the the
honor happy accidents via via via
intentional
mishaps as it were i think that's an
excellent point you make there let's ask
the officers
um for their reflections on how
practice and how this all those points
um but just let's go try and ask the
officers that they're happy to give them
give us their perspective on the way
that ons
in particular or perhaps some other
generalizations
and i would open this to any of the
officers here present
and i mean every single one of you feel
free
to throw whatever you have into the ring
come on be brave
you can see emily's chomping at the bit
thank you chair and of course if any
other officers want to join in then
then please do um so i would reflect the
the feedback that members have given
about the
informal interactions and missing those
so there has been less opportunity for
just
catching up with a counselor in the
corridor just
having those very quick conversations
but also that more personal side of
those conversations as well and
particularly i think
the kind of welfare conversations that
quite often we have
when we're in person you know just the
how are you doing how are the family and
so on and so forth
i do think there's been benefit to the
um additional contact on teams or
or phone calls and and i think probably
i've spoken to
members who don't have the flexibility
of coming into the office
during the working day so particularly
those councillors that
are in full-time employment they've been
able to to have a telephone call quickly
during the day whereas
normally they might have been um
prevented from doing so or just
counselors that their role doesn't bring
them into the office as much
so i think i've probably spoken to more
members but um less frequently
on a kind of individual basis and
certainly i've been very appreciative of
members being very flexible about my
children appearing in
teams calls and interrupting meetings
and i thank you all for that
thank you chair thank you very much
council carter you wanted to follow up
yes we still haven't arranged to play
eight five still now yet
there's still time there we go there's a
happy accident kathy good morning
um i obviously in my role um tend to
meet with
um a lot of you in in various different
groups but and one of the things i would
say that i've noticed in the last year
is that members contact me by
a wider range of methods and you know
whether that's
chat on teams or whether it's whatsapp
yes of course
and still email and still the old
telephone call
um but certainly a greater diversity of
means
and one of the things i really enjoyed
is that when members have called me
that we have turned on our cameras and
and so rather than just the phone call
that actually um we've been virtually
face to face which has been great
yeah i was actually going to ask if that
irritated officers because i hope
you know to to impose too often
any other members um any other officers
wish to comment on the
the way the relationships have gone and
can go
john
i think you've got a bit of a buzz but
then yeah so um
i've quite actually once i've got over
got over the horror of
having to do about you know arrange
virtual meetings and get counsellors on
board
i've quite enjoyed them and i um
i know cancers do miss the interaction
with each other but
normally before a meeting we were in
there a little bit earlier and we do
have some interaction
teams messages has been really really
useful
to me because it's instant so um and
councillors have started to use those a
lot more so for me
i can see that actually if i'm in a
meeting and people have got issues
they've been able to to
instant message me and i know we had
skype before but
with teams it's it's a lot easier and so
for me i've really enjoyed the use of
teams the frustrations i have is when
i'm working from home and this goes back
to
cancer epping on's point um i do
sometimes have a really slow broadband
and that drives me up the wall when i'm
trying to do something or
expected to do you know a meeting or
going into something and
everything just slows down and you have
to log off
and go back in again to get back in and
i do find that frustrating but on the
whole
i think virtual meetings and and the the
um communication around them have been
you know once we got going and into it
have been really really good
and for overview and scrutiny i think
it's given an increased flexibility
and for calling people in for witnesses
um you've been able to do that without
actually people having to travel in so
we've been able to get
you know wider maybe selection of people
able to join the meeting
whereas you know if you're asking them
to come into endeavor house it's a lot
more
logistically um difficult so for me
um that has given us a flexibility that
we haven't seen before so i'm
definitely all for it thank you very
much jan actually i think this
question of flexibility is something
we're going to return to over and over
again and that we are
now aware of more methods of working
more methods of meeting more methods of
doing everything
and that we don't need to be confined
and constrained
to the practices of the past
because we've discovered there are
others i was going to ask though
specifically on the preparation of
reports and the extra work involved in
preparing for meetings has that and i
hear i look to henriette
who has undertaken a great deal of the
workload
of preparing for our meetings do you
have any thoughts henrietta
on whether it has become much harder to
prepare for the meetings in the course
of the last year
sorry to put you on the spot
um not really i think um
i think maybe in some ways it's been
easier because we haven't had to print
out
and organize dispatch and that sort of
thing which we sort of going for where
we're from anyway
and so for us as committee officers it
has been easier
i think and communication has been easy
as well because there's no
you i mean in some ways it's been easy
in other ways
i suppose when you worked in here you
sort of got to desk and talk to people
directly
and now you have to call them but i
think overall i don't think has made
that much difference really
um i think preparation reports and
agendas um
it's just a different way of working and
it's just trying to get used to that i
think
thanks very much henriette i just wanted
to establish that whether we were
actually making things more difficult
for officers or not
um right any of the other themes that
members would like to pick up on i think
we're moving forward
through them and some of them have been
touched upon use of witnesses the
quality of the reports
we've discussed briefly the potential
for working groups and committee member
involvement
perhaps member responsibility uh time
management in meetings is something i'm
always a little bit
obsessed by because i'm aware that
meetings that go on too long and don't
follow a
clear direction will end up just going
in circles and not actually coming to
any
any forms of conclusion or adding any
value so any thoughts on time management
and similar matters
nobody's rushing forward on that one all
right so uh
do members do members understand why we
try to operate i think both keith and
myself have
operated in the same basic principle
of trying to provide direction to the
meeting and shape
but it's members that we need to
actually supply the content
you don't want to hear us groaning on
all the time okay
councilman mclaren thank you chair um
i think time management
in fact has been perhaps one of the
downsides of actually
our virtual meetings
it's very easy when everybody's in a
different place
and some i'm not talking particularly
about this committee
but some committees have actually gone
on for quite a long time
now that might be right but what you
lose
is the impetus by the committee
to come to a conclusion and i think we
should be
aware of that i i've not been aware in
this committee
that we've ever not time managed or the
chairs of not time managed
but it is very off-putting to be in a
long-winded committee
and you don't get the best of the
counsellor's commitment to
a resolution thank you i'm already aware
today that in the course of the last
hour we've covered more ground than we
would have done in a remote meeting
i would estimate this would have taken
another half an hour to get this far and
to cover this
many this breadth of range of points um
that's just another observation from oh
suddenly realized yes we're getting
somewhere counselor
thank you chair yeah i think the time
management of our meetings has gone
it's gone pretty well and you know it's
thanks to the officers and to members of
the committee that they have
um picking up on councillor grandin's
point uh
about um being asked to speak when they
haven't at that point got anything to
say that
that can be an embarrassment to the
chair and to the and to the
members of the committee in that there
are
a few occasions when i've got my list
and the first five people haven't had
anything to say
and you wonder if anybody's going to say
anything face to face we
we're more likely to get people in a
sensible order speaking
um but if if we are going to have
more remote meetings we need to just
find a different way of doing that
perhaps when we had when we had our
face-to-face pre-meetings
we we did get two or three people who
would say
well on that on that item i would like
to say such and such and such and such
so you know would it be beneficial if i
spoke first because it will get the
discussion going we because we haven't
had pre-meetings of that sort
we just haven't had that informal
discussion immediately prior to the
meeting and i think that would be useful
if we could find some way of
of doing that what what about the matter
of scoping of topics the practice we
used to carry out on a regular basis was
scoping
um pre-examination of something that we
would be looking at in greater detail
uh further down the line um do we want
to
and it was a good reasons why we didn't
think of a lot of scoping done this last
year because
we had other priorities changed shall we
say
but i think we obviously have to
consider if there are areas we want to
scope and how we're going to go about
that
or as some members suggested to me they
found
that scoping was just our repeating
ourselves that we were quite capable of
going straight into the subject
and examining it with a sim with one
report rather than
as it were doing it twice there's two
few points
to consider there either one of those
might be valid
any thoughts on that councillor grandin
thank you i would say the the
idea of scoping is a good idea
um but it should be short and sharp
you know maybe not time limit it but but
be aware that this isn't a big
discussion it's just
to get to a point um and and it's not
the meeting in itself
so if we kind of set ourselves
parameters this is
this is not the whole discussion
let's we're only going to look at this
this you know who who are we going to
get to speak or what are
what are our parameters and limit it and
maybe
not actually time limit it physically by
saying this only last 10 minutes or 15
minutes or whatever
but have in our minds that this should
be a short sharp thing and it's not the
meeting in itself
whereas i think we sometimes forgot that
previously
um so that's maybe just a different
approach too i i quite understand so
providing a focus for scoping before
rather than trying to do it all in one
go counselor cast
thank you very much um i think the
chairing of our opening
scrutiny meetings has been excellent and
um
we could have easily found that meetings
went on a lot longer
and didn't find direction without
two very good chairs or
looking after it the scope inside of
things i don't
the pre-meeting and scoping i don't see
um that much difference between the two
i think that pre-meeting
is quite crucial because um
you can you can never report off by
heart you can know every single word in
it
but until you go into the pre-meeting
and that gets churned about and people
start opening up
different avenues and things like that
that's when you really
start getting deeply into the content of
a report
so um i think i'll be pleased to see the
pre-meeting back i think um
i think that helps me quite a lot um
with with these meetings with uh
direction but um
yeah the scope inside of things i do
feel that that's
we're doing the same thing twice a
little bit and i
i don't feel it's as necessary maybe
as other councillors but um
yeah i but that pre-meeting to me is is
a really important part of this process
i saw quite a few nods in this
discussion of pre-meetings and obviously
it's something i've always been in favor
of because i think
preparation pays off half an hour or
quarter of an hour can actually
save you a great deal more time further
into the meeting
do i get the impression from members
that they would like to see pre-meetings
be
back being adopted as a standard
procedure cathy do you have a point on
this
basically um pre-meetings have been much
welcomed by officers and they have found
it very helpful
in terms of um understanding what
scrutiny wants to achieve
but in terms of um the scoping
um i would say that and you know if we
get the right background and the right
data
in the scoping information that we bring
to you that
and that is key in assisting you to look
at
what are the key issues that you really
need to get your teeth into
when you look at the substantive item so
that would be
um my suggestion so scoping as a method
of
producing um a targeted report
indeed and in fact effectively that's
what the scoping is there for it's not
to do the report itself
it is to prepare the ground and the
areas that the committee wishes to
follow up on because i have to confess
with to you all as chairs that the four
of us get together or either face to
face or
remotely and in some ways
we are effectively carrying out a
scoping process in those chairs meetings
but frankly
that is a process that should be shared
amongst all the members of the committee
not just the chairs and the vice chair
so right that's four of us
and that's well it's a significant
proportion of the committees it's about
a third
effect of two committees even so um
there's a lot more people with a lot
more input so i think that's something
that we could consider as a
recommendation
yes emily thank you chair if i can just
add to some of the comments made
by the strategic director around the
benefits of the scoping document from an
officer perspective
um i think it does a number of really
useful things
it enables officers to really understand
the nature of the scrutiny that the
committee wants to undertake so what
information do you want presented
how can we provide you those assurances
where it's an assurance piece of work
and what are the what are the data sets
and who are the
uh witnesses who would really add to the
the benefits of that scrutiny exercise
the other thing that scoping does is it
enables the committee to identify the
value add
so you really test that topic is it um
going to add value to that issue by the
committee looking at it so it really
enables you to
kind of narrow down perhaps you know you
start off with the at the start of the
year with
a multitude of topics that you might
want to look into and that scoping
exercise really helps you to then funnel
down and pick
those topics that will really make a
difference to the operation of the
council
and so i do think it's really helpful
chair and i think
perhaps where we've come unstuck before
when we've used the scope and document
is where we've presented you with a
blank document and we've tried to
in committee actually fill that escape
and document in and so something that i
would like to take forward chair is that
actually we come to you with an officer
prepared scoping document
and then it's for the committee to test
that and to see if there's anything that
you want to add
or remove from that scoping exercise and
i think chair that will make the
um exercise less repetitive
and also perhaps the committee will feel
less constrained by the the scoping
exercise itself i think what we're
looking for
as a committee today is is basically
establishing our own ideas on what best
practice
should be and it's up to us to decide
what that best practice should be
and then to carry it out so obviously if
we're going to be doing it we need to
have a
we put in to put our own ideas into that
thanks very much for that emily
uh council mclaren thank you chair
um i think this highlights
one of the items that i was going to
bring up anyway
which is about training of the committee
so i think we mentioned a lot of
activities
the committee changes people change
and i think there would be some benefit
in going through
some of these things in a training
situation
so that counselors coming onto the
committee understand
what it is perhaps they're trying to
achieve i think it's as basic as that to
be honest
some of the most effective training
we've ever held on scrutiny in the
course of the last four years has
actually been face to face at um
i wouldn't call them away days um but
they have been useful to go
somewhere else and to tackle a topic or
tackle a subject and that might be
something that can be brought back in
now that we have potential for freedom
uh counselor carter
we have to admit feeling rather
disadvantaged i've only ever done
scrutiny
on teams so i started just before the uh
the coverage truck um
i would feel face to face very
beneficial in some
doing some more training very beneficial
terms like scoping and the pre-meetings
i've not really experienced i've not
never done that so um
i've only known teams i've been known
for the benefits to that i've
gained somewhat of advantage to that
i'd be interested to see the other side
of the story
there is some excellent material from
what was known as the center for public
scrutiny and i believe has now been
renamed to
center for scrutiny in governance
okay there is an organization
that does produce i mean in fact um it
might be worth
pulling those um some of the basic
documents about scrutiny
out again i have a folder full of them i
must confess
i haven't looked at them a little bit in
the recent year but uh
they are there and they do establish
some of the ideas in fact they could be
i would just suggest that they some of
those central ones i've got a list of
the
um the basic ones that i think could be
distributed to all the members
of any scrutiny committee as a matter of
course
that would be my suggestion only though
okay let's see any harm in it
um and obviously there are other links
but these are actual
fundamental basic central guides to
the scrutiny process um you know they're
not long
that's the big advantage then not long
okay anything else from anybody please
because i've lost my screen
you can't see my crib sheet i'm hoping
somebody's got their crib sheet handy
for the various topics chair if i could
just briefly
say um a little bit about the time
management while you're looking for your
document um i i think a lot
of the credit for the time management of
the meeting should go to henriette
who um did prepare a crib sheet
for the chairs for every meeting and
that was a really
big help um so big thank you henry
for that yes
absolutely couldn't agree more i mean
basically the
preparation and let's be honest about it
in the online meetings because
you normally you can share this stuff
and you can just go through the agenda
and you know the form of words to use
but for the remote meetings and
sometimes because it's been
had to be very structured a script
has been necessary and it has made life
a lot easier
um so if i sound incredibly glib it's
not me it's henriette's writing
um but it's effectively it does make
life
possible i think is the biggest word
otherwise it would take longer
and it's terrible if you find you've
forgotten something
um towards the end of the meeting the
recommendation hasn't been put
and it has to you have to come back to
it at a later point you know
stuff like that it can happen so thanks
very much to henriette
okay i've got this list back up again
what about
recommendations that the scrutiny
committees make
to cabinet to council
and indeed to officers how the women
members feel that we have dealt with
making our recommendations and ensuring
they've been followed up on
cancer evangel thank you chairman
um as a relatively new member to
overview and scrutiny
um one of the the very point you're
alluding to is this one that concerns me
is i don't
see a structured mechanism from
getting the feedback that
recommendations have been carried
through
particularly in a timely fashion
and so i think that's something that we
need to look at
it's one thing to spend hours
scrutinizing something making
recommendations
get them ex agreed that they they should
be done
this i think much more important or very
important after that is to understand
that
a they have been done how they've been
done and and have we achieved the
desired impact
of those recommendations um so that's
one
area that i would be keen to see us
address in a more structured way
and i think the issue of scoping for me
is is in a sense down to um the overview
and scrutiny committee
being cognizant of
what the council is trying to achieve
particularly
in in particular time period so for
example the next
fun um municipal year and and
how we're driving towards getting those
achieved
um i i noticed that there are some uh
elements of the report where we talk
about kpis but i certainly for one don't
recognize that those kpis have come
forward and
what are they and what are they
measuring and so on and so forth so this
is an area i think that
could do with more scrutiny if i put it
that way
so um that one reason i raised that very
point and
the other thing of course there are
instances where recommendations have
been made
to for example cabinet a matter of
pre-scrutinizing a cabinet decision
and then cabinet have been taken the cat
taken the scrutiny recommendation
into account in making their final
decision and
at times that has also come back to
scrutiny
and at least it hasn't been um and it's
obviously a possibility at any time so
that is one way you can actually say
well this is what has
resulted this is what then resulted but
there are others that i agree with you
are a little more nebulous
we're not entirely certain as to whether
this will be taken forward and i do
believe you're right
i think this is something that needs to
be tracked but we need to find a
mechanism
to do that and to make sure that that
mechanism can be followed
it it's very easy you focus
each time you've got the agenda you
focus on the next
meeting your next item you look at the
work plan on a regular basis but you
don't
tend to look back on the work plan
unless of course you'll you're doing the
minutes which is the
next time you look back at them and by
which time they may or may not have had
a time period in which it's been
possible to carry out any recommendation
so yes i think that's something that the
committee would want to look at
councillor welcome
thank you chair um following on from
what uh
young said about um we we need to have a
look at the actions that are planned by
the
our districts in formulating our
um our plans that that's okay up to a
point
but there are a number of issues which
are raised
by our residents which need to be
scrutinized
and are not really anything to do with
the next
year or two years i mean i just throw
out one thing
and i i've been asked why
why hasn't this
scrutinize rural transport um
because nobody seems to be scrutinizing
it
um it's nothing it's not something that
is
directly a a responsibility of this
authority
or our councils but it is a key issue
to a lot of the residents in the rural
areas of faber and mid-suffolk
so at some point i will suggest that
but it's that sort of issue that i think
we need to make sure we've got into
our work plan the issues that affect
the residents perhaps not just of our
two districts it might be
that it would be a joint scrutiny with
other
districts as well but we mustn't close
our eyes to those sorts of issues
i mean it is quite distinctly obviously
a matter of for the county council on
the larger scale
but obviously it affects our residents
on the on the local scale
and it's always been an issue i think in
local government across the board
how do you how do you cope with some of
the matters that are dealt with at
different levels
and there can be sort of i wouldn't say
turf war we have had experience of
trying to
uh do joint scrutiny across different
councils before
we set up a joint scrutiny task force
which involved baba mid suffolk
west suffolk ipswich sadly not east
and suffolk county council that may be
something that could be done on the
subject of rural transport
and in fact the joint scrutiny that's
just a suggestion and i only throw that
in
but it's certainly worth i think it's
the committee to
work that out in their next year's plan
and the years to come
any other thoughts um i was going to ask
if there was anything that
had come out of the annual report that
anybody wanted to raise
any thoughts um it suggests it just says
chairs reports to council it should be
in
fact it's a record of what we did this
is largely prepared by henrietta the
forward supplied by
the two chairs but obviously we've had
sight of it and uh
approved of what of the content did
anybody have anything they wish to say
before we
present that to those councils annual
report
thank you i think there might be a
couple of um
errors who might want to take care of in
these reports before we present them to
council you mean typos yes yes
okay i mean the typos i always slip
through
i'm afraid yeah i know i don't know if
we can change them now because the
papers have been issued is that correct
henriette
yeah that's correct i'm afraid you'll
have to blame me in keith
i did actually spot one grammatical
error that i frankly thought well if
anybody spots that it just shows that
they're paying attention
have read the report did you know the
ordnance survey whenever it publishes a
map
makes a deliberate mistake so that if
anybody tries to copy it
the ordnance survey can prove that uh it
has been copied
and this is a quite deliberate ploy on
the os
every single os map contains a
deliberate error
and that's what we're going to call
these okay let's see if there's anything
else
on the topics list the um themes
does henriette oh sorry jackassee he
wanted to say something sorry
indeed um something that um officers
um have highlighted to me was um how
they find
the benefit of joint scrutiny of
particular items
where perhaps the decision by one
council could have an impact on another
and a good example of that was the joint
scrutiny of the insourcing of public
realm
where in one world that could have been
done just by baber
but obviously the impact of insourcing
meant that we were
you know entering into a shared service
and so
and i know that the assistant director
and corporate manager
and took away some and useful pointers
and from the discussion at scrutiny um
that would relate to the entirety of the
new shared service on our
and you know we'll be integrating that
into their thinking
um as they prepare for that later in the
year
actually i think they're recalling that
in in-house and outhouse service that
was a direct benefit in the fact that
the two councils had
got experience of two different methods
of service provision
and we were able to compare and contrast
and make a reasoned
recommendation on that basis was very
useful
having direct member experience and the
two separate councils experience
in coming to the conclusions so yes i
found that very helpful
right members um i see a few more themes
that we haven't touched upon but i don't
know
that we're going to add a great deal
more um do we want to start thinking
about
what recommendations we would make as it
were
to this committee as it is in the future
council represent
i'm sorry i did have uh another point to
raise with regard to the report
so it relates to the activity of the
western
software community safety partnership um
and in in the in the report he talks
about
one of the issues being violence against
women and girls
men and boys and
i'm just wondering whether in the
current
climate where we shouldn't actually that
shouldn't just be individuals
um rather or or do we actually then need
to
itemize every kind of gender position
well it's the terminology used
in the government legislation that's
coming forward i think there's an
as this an act being prepared on that
very subject came up in the queen's
speech
and it's become the terminology that's
been used originally it was violence
against women and girls borg
and it was quite rightly pointed out
that the in a number of small number of
instances
it also existed against men and boys so
it was just extended we're following i
suppose in the
convention of everybody else in the area
and that that's also what i believe the
community safety partnership
do as well they're just following in uh
in the uh
well i won't call it the fashion of the
day but i will say it's the terminology
being used
in in the field
hear what you say but i still i still
think it needs to be looked at because
um there is violence against
transgender people for example it's well
documented
and it just seems to me that this
description is a bit restrictive
i think i think the trouble with any
description is whether you either
you how broadly you define it and i
think a lot of people get hung up
too much a little bit on on
the definitions when the very principle
is quite
clear that you don't do this to anybody
but there is a definite and i don't
think it can be argued
there is absolutely no question that the
vast majority
of domestic violence takes place against
women and girls
all the evidence states that and the
white ribbon
is there for a reason non-tolerant
tolerance
of of such behavior uh councillor welum
yeah just to say chair that we were
reviewing
the action under five particular
headings or priorities
and that's what the priority is called
so we couldn't call it something
different
but we can feed back that
this this point has been raised
community safety partnership also does
have a representative
of both councils on it so those um many
members wanting to raise those points
can of course raise it directly
with the representatives of each council
council carter
just a quick point term violence against
men is actually widely
under-reported um due to um
there are social cues that men will not
um come forward
so whilst it is widely reported at the
majority instance of recorded instances
violence against women there are many
reasons why violence against
men and also violence against children
and boys
who are not widely reported so
it may be a hidden but it could be
against violence in general i think i
think
it's absolutely definite that violence
against women and girls is also
equally under-reported and in fact and
this is a known fact and has been
for very many years and is getting
increasing recognition
when um a subject like this comes up in
the queen's speech
i think you have to recognize that it is
actually achieving
a much greater degree of political
attention
than has been the case in the past and i
think that's only to the good
regardless of where it comes from okay
i don't want to get bogged down in one
small area it's not a small it's an
important area
but as in terms of the overview of
scrutiny and
looking at our work i think you can get
stuck in a rats there a little bit
council carter
well actually i'll i'll ask a question
out of a meeting i'm sorry i just can
ask
you you mentioned the white ribbon i
wanted to know what person is for
it's a it's a campaign that was started
a year or so ago and
i think it was brought to the scrutiny
committee by an officer of the council
although it was not something that could
be promoted
but it's uh non-toleration of violence
against women and girls
a little person is a prostate cancer
black and white so one for men one for
women i know i'm an equal
one right well my virtue signaling is
over for the moment
let's move on um to see if there's
anything else we want to move towards
any recommendations to um the future
overview scrutiny committee
kathy sorry it was just um before you
moved on picking up the point about
key performance indicators um that
absolutely
impact and being able to measure it is
key
and and you'll recall those of you who
are able to attend the
all member workshops in last week that
we are going to be um reviewing our
performance indicators
and but also and as well as that
and neither do you have the delivery
plans and you'll have a suite of things
you'll have the delivery plans
you'll have the quarterly performance
reporting the quarterly finance
reporting and and so moving forward
you've got you're going to have a suite
of things that actually
you know and will help to bring together
and to be able to focus on impact
i was just going to add on something
about i mean member involvement which
occurred to me
um in terms of the understanding of key
performance indicators is
that the cabinet meetings help but
both baber and mid african sometimes
joined cabinets
often go quite some depth into key
performance indicators
in the quarterly reports and i'd
recommend those to
any member of any scrutiny committee to
keep a track of we don't do it here
it is done at cabinet and any member of
council can go to any cabinet
um or watch it um obviously online
because it'll be broadcast so you don't
even need to go to the meeting
but the the papers and the kpis i think
adrian would agree with me there that
they
they have they have also been somewhat
improved in terms of the
um presentation they are a lot easier to
read now
um because they pick out the key key
performance indicators as opposed to an
exhaustive listed tiny tiny print
which was useful if you wanted to drill
down to that level
but this is a lot a lot easier to use
and understand
so returning then if i may to the point
about
do we have any recommendations that we
would make to
future incarnations of overview and
scrutiny
i was just scribbling one of two things
which might be helpful
and one of one of those was to consider
for each uh separate overview and
scrutiny
committee to consider um
reducing the number of joint meetings
in order to include
issues relevant only to their own
authority or perhaps
for one of our committees to actors
like the lead committee on a an issue
that affects
that that district most but obviously
not to exclude
the other uh members of the other
committee coming along
that's a very innovative suggestion in
fact we could get
twice the amount of work covered by
using the two committees separately
obviously obviously we'll need to work
together to draw up
the two the two plans otherwise we might
almost mirror but not quite so we we'd
end up with
doing twice as much work for
half the benefit um and i think it's
worth bringing
it's worth bringing in um the points
about um
having an informal um
pre-meeting um and also
i think perhaps for the chair chairs and
vice chairs to consider
how best how best to
um integrate scoping into our agendas
well can we just start with one we can
probably agree quite quickly on
pre-meetings
obviously right at the start of the list
uh half
an hour pre-meeting prior to an overview
and scrutiny committee meeting
be considered standard practice okay
and therefore that we'd meet half an
hour beforehand as standard practice
um so we could we could alter that by
exception
but standard practice would be so that
would be one possible recommendation
i think i'd be happy to well councillor
casten was the one who
led that off we'd like to propose that
councillor caston
yes please mr chairman do we have a
seconder for that councillor
councillor muller so we have a proposal
and a second or for that one
uh we'll come back to the votes on these
later on okay
now any other recommendations councillor
grandin
thank you chair um i'm just a little bit
concerned about councillor wenham's
um uh matters that he was saying
in that there seem to be quite a lot of
things that the two councils do overlap
on
and so we could be in a situation where
there's a meeting from one uh scrutiny
committee
meeting on one council and then the
other council
repeats because i'd say we
have more in common than we do
different and so while i agree we should
have separate committee meetings
um and and keep that but i just thought
for me i would have thought the balance
would be more joint ones
but but have separate ones but
less often than the joint ones is would
have been my view
whereas if i understood you correctly i
thought you were saying the opposite i'm
sorry if i misunderstood
okay um it's just a matter of
definitions keith you'd like to
elaborate on that well no i think i
would agree with councillor grandin that
perhaps the majority would end up as
joint meetings but i think we've
what we've when we've looked at our work
plan it's tended to
be let's see what we can do jointly and
then
with the time left over we'll do our own
thing i think we ought to
each separate committee should decide
what their priorities are
and then see which of those can be
brought together as joint
scrutinies very clearly some areas where
it has to be mid-suffolk that deals with
gateway 14
it has to be um perhaps
that deals with the parking policy
that's being done it has to be each
individual council that
uh is individual council's scrutiny
committee
that is charged with performing that
function
questions etc various things that are
specific
to that council they actually are
less common than the interests we have
in
shared in common and there would always
be the risk of course if we
separate too much stuff and both
councils look at it
separately or one dozen one doesn't
that one council's um scrutiny committee
may not have come to the same conclusion
as the other council's scrutiny
committee and there is a possibility of
some
problems there which is when where in
fact you have
by having a joint overview and scrutiny
committee you avoid that problem
um we don't have um a split
i think i can recall in three or four
years
one occasion where there was a very
clear mid-suffolk
babera split and as it came down to it
it involved the use the only time i've
ever seen it of the jones casting vote
um and in fact i think the matter was
resolved afterwards anyway
but that's a rarity is my point and i
i would hope that a scrutiny committee
would not
be deliberately accidentally putting
itself in a difficult position
and the council's in a difficult
position
so we've got the general principle that
we
will mostly meet
as a shared council but we have to have
and i've always wanted us to have the
ability to
and i hope most members to be able to
meet on our own if there's something
that is of particular
interest council mclaren
thank you chair yes i think we
underestimate
the value of joint meetings
the very fact that everybody brings
different experience
in terms of council procedure
in terms of experience of where they've
been in the past
and i think the joint meetings do bring
together
that uh you know with the six
with six members on each scrutiny
you can't embrace all the skill and
knowledge
that is in a group of twelve and i agree
with
councillor grandin um i think we should
make the most of the joint meetings and
then
specify and we and and of course in baby
this year
we've had one or two meetings that have
had to be separate because of
of um situations that have arisen so
that's going to happen anyway
to that very point in fact when i was
preparing the um
report and going through what we dealt
with
the course of the year there were
moments where we were
very short of members for a baber
meeting with the committee cons composed
of six people
um it was it became possible for us not
to be correct
when we reduced the number of
councillors we also heavily reduced the
number of
councillors on scrutiny and i believe we
may have re
moved taken the number two low
i believe six is possibly at a risk
for both councils and i think this would
be a recommendation to make to
um emily's department jan's department
whatever we want to call it but
fundamentally
i wonder if we should be making a
recommendation that the size of the
scrutiny committees be increased either
to seven
or even eight members and the risk of
becoming
incorporate when dealing with matters of
one council
does exist as we stand six is not many
it doesn't take a lot of uh absenteeism
and we are restricted to some extent in
what the makeup of our members can be
because specific
roles are prohibited from being on
scrutiny
as substitutes then there's the group
rules that require that
your substitute for you can only be from
the same political grouping
and i think with only six members we
occasionally run at risk of not being
able to do a proper job because we
actually call it so i would i would ask
members what their thoughts are on
a recommendation to um which department
would it be emily who should we be
making that recommendation to cabinet or
council
thank you chair it would be a
recommendation to the full council
because the council
is responsible for allocating the
committees and
and the apportionment of places of
course that is going to happen
this evening for mid-suffolk and
tomorrow evening for
for baby so the committee will need to
proceed in its current format
at least for the immediate future what i
suggest
chair is that officers take away that
recommendation to explore increasing the
number
and then we can have a look at the
makeup and those positions as you've
rightly said that are excluded
from sitting on the committee and
perhaps come up with a recommendation of
a a sensible number that could be
accommodated by the various groups in
terms of
the the membership that that so that
recommendation would be for this to be
taken away
examined and then eventually presented
to council with some suggested ideas
um i'd be happy does that mean i'm happy
to propose that if somebody would second
that council carter
so we'll do that as a second
recommendation and we'll take the vote
on that later that is
if you've got the wording for that
henriette more or less fine
okay and we're looking for concrete
recommendations here but rather than
vague things saying well
we're going to carry on meeting we're
going to carry on meeting in joint
session anyway
we can't specify that as a
recommendation because it's what we do
anyway
um council mclaren then councillor
casten
thank you chair i want to make a
recommendation about training
i think we underestimate the value
of being able to explore
so many committee members will have a
sort of a vague idea of what they're
supposed to be doing or not doing
and even making recommendations in
itself
is a training issue and i would like to
see a more comprehensive training
program for this committee
training and making recommendations is a
good recommendation to make
fine um do you want to add to that
i mean with something comprehensive i'm
not talking about
i certainly attended i think when i was
a newly elected
a scrutiny training which was held
downstairs and that included everybody
but i i think he needs to be more
tailor-made
to to the situations i mean
emily you know that in our situation in
baber we've had one or two
instances where we've all had to learn
very quickly
about certain how to handle certain
situations
and i i do i've always believed in
training for people how would you like
to phrase the
recommendation i mean i'm just trying to
think that yeah sorry
what one the the overview scrutiny
committee
um recommends that a training program be
established be established
to work on an annual basis encompassing
emily maybe you can help us on this
sorry sir perhaps if i just talk for a
little while and then
councilman mclaren can perhaps and think
about how she might want to wear the
recommendation but to just give a
a slightly wider context so i absolutely
agree that i think a bespoke
um training session specifically for
members of the committee would be really
beneficial and for that to be
wider than just the training item that
you have on the
work plan for the next meeting so i
think we should take that off and hold
something separate
i also think that there is um
scope for holding training for other
members outside of scrutiny who are
actually coming to scrutiny to present
items
or to provide feedback and actually
sometimes it's beneficial for the
cabinet members to
have some training around scrutiny so
that they can understand what your
function is and their
therefore how to respond to that item
there are a number of partners we could
use for that kind of training
and of course we can do some of that um
ourselves as well or support some of
that ourselves through
in-house offices and chair the other
thing that might be beneficial
um alongside that training session is to
then have a separate session
outside of a formal meeting about
developing your work
plan and your areas of scrutiny i'm
hearing a number of things and i think
it fits into counsellor wellam's
comments about
whether you hold joint scrutinies or or
separate scrutinies and and part of that
is categorizing
the types of scrutiny that you do so
there's obviously going to be quite an
internal focus for scrutiny you have a
clear role in
holding the cabinet to account
scrutinizing
um in a in an advanced way forthcoming
policies and
decisions and changes to how we operate
things like that
but there's also the opportunity for
external scrutiny so you can look at
outside bodies you can look at those
wider community issues
i was hearing and the rural transport i
also heard very loudly about broadband
provision i thought that could be a very
good topic for
for the overview and scrutiny committee
and then you have um
your response role which is very much
individualized
for each council so those are things
like the call-ins
or the petitions review that we had in
in baby in the last municipal year
um which which none of us had come
across before and
obviously as you say we were developing
the protocol for that as as we went so
i think there's probably two sessions
outside of a form meeting that could be
very beneficial bespoke training and
then
um a session around developing your work
programme
thank you chair could the recommendation
then be that a bespoke
training program be um prepared
for swiss for implementation as early as
possible
that's what grant and they'll come back
to councillor cast and the councillor
casting i did see your hand but is this
on the same subject as councillor
yeah yeah i thought incorrectly would
you mind if i come back to you
councillor casten
no matter thank you councilman mclaren
councillor yes i think bespoke
i i i think it i want it to embrace
all the possible aspects of overview and
scrutiny
um if that is possible for a
recommendation
the bespoke would seem to fit the bill
there but you don't like it
as opposed to off the peg is what i
meant you know something
and perhaps some um
recognition of what committee members
themselves
feel they need so we're actually making
a judgment here
but i guarantee that around this
committee
there will be different areas that worry
commitment or you know what committee
members would like
are we going in the cart before the
horse if we ask the committee members to
advise
no no no no no what i'm saying is i want
the training program to recognise that
there will be different needs for
different people
okay so can we find the form of words
for recommendation three on
training that you'll be happy with
councillor brandon you might have a
suggestion there
no i haven't but i just wanted sorry i
only wanted to simply say that could
this
training be um sort of more of a
or part of it be have a workshop element
so that there's it's kind of interactive
um rather than us being all of it being
us being trained but there's also an
interactive element
so that i think it can be whatever we
want it to be effectively
there's a lot of resources available and
we know we have the offices of
the knowledge and we also know that
whatever the
cf center for public scrutiny is now
called
also have a lot of information that we
can use and courses
and individual members and are able to
go
outside courses i've been down to london
uh more than once
so as keith's um we got lost uh
big city you know really really big
place anyway uh
putting that aside emily thank you chair
i've just um
typed out a form of words and i'd just
like to put that to the committee so
the recommendation would be to hold a
bespoke training session for committee
members
encompassing all elements of the
scrutiny function and taking into
account the skills and experience of
individual members and what we could do
chair is before the session is do a bit
of a skills audit so just send around a
questionnaire so that can feed in
to the trainer who's delivering the
session and the purpose of that session
would be to produce said
program i mean that should be the point
surely because the session
should not be a dead end it should be a
starting point to produce the
program that i believe you want council
mclaren is that correct
thank you chair and thank you emily i
couldn't have put it better myself
i think what we have in the uh voting is
that it is the
recommendation as read by the committee
clerk
that's what will that's how we'll do it
then right any other further
recommendations i think
sorry councillor caston you were next
thank you very much mr chairman um
i'm not sure how you'd put this into a
um recommendation but on the um scrutiny
committee i would like to see um more
witnesses from um
maybe the um the different levels
because we we have very good witnesses
from mid-suffolk
um for instance to help explain
like if we're looking at homelessness an
expert witness
an outreach worker or that kind of thing
that
you know with the um remit to tell us
things exactly how they are
as they see them and complete free reign
to um
say how they feel about things and like
also tenants
um and you you use people like that i
know
it's been quite difficult to get people
to come forward because everyone's very
busy and
um it you know it it has been
difficult to get people engaged but um i
think that would be really useful
for this committee um we have fantastic
reports but
if we peel back another layer and
um and look into that that would
make it really useful for
recommendations to cabinet just to
get a bit more um experience in that way
and also i
i don't think there's anything to stop
members of the scrutiny committee going
out with
well obviously at the moment there is
but um in the
in the normal world going out maybe with
outreach workers or something in
in preparation for a um scrutiny meeting
to
actually see what it's like on the
ground
um but i'm yeah not quite sure how that
is a recommendation but that's the
that's along the lines that i was
thinking you'd be suggesting
the increa an increased use of a wider
range of witnesses
that be the fair way of placing it okay
so if you'd like to recommend that we
have a seconder for that one
councillor again right fine so there's
four now we've got the pre-meetings what
was the second one emily
henry
sorry so we have four recommendations i
do need to
just catch counselor carsten's
recommendation a second
and the first one is that pre-meetings
of half an hour are adopted as a
standard practice and that was proposed
by councillor casten and councillor
muller
the second recommendation is recommends
that officers work on a proposal for
increasing the size of each committed to
eight members to enable robust scrutiny
for the sovereign committees
but they should be examined basically it
doesn't have to be those specific
so to increase the size of each
committee
we'll just take them in person just in
case
it's fine the third recommendation is to
hold a bespoke training session for
committee members
encompassing all elements of the
scrutiny function
and taking into account the skills and
experience of individual members
and the final recommendation was uh to
include the inc
sorry it was inclusion of chair
uh
sorry increased use of a wider range of
witnesses would that cover every bets
yes counselor
but believe me answer the cast and also
mentioned about externalizing the
meetings with
with witnesses to actually go into for
a counsellors to go and see how things
are outside of a meeting rather than
that so i don't know how that would be
worded into recommendations
subject i suppose to governance
arrangements because at some places we
would not be appropriately
going but yes i don't see why that but
that's possible anyway
effectively it doesn't need a resolution
or a recommendation
that is a matter of the personal will of
any counsellor
to make contact with the group and say
look can i come and see you
we don't need a recommendation to act as
what we're elected to do
you know so i think that's probably um
it would i don't see a point in the
recommendation to be honest i don't
think it adds value
however i do think it's a good idea
uh well let's keep the recommendation to
the increased use of a wider range of
internal and external witnesses
and then we've covered all the bets
around there
something we've referred to earlier on
in the meeting was the
committees be prepared to consider the
use of
task and finish groups on individual
projects
to enable them to take undertake a wider
range of subjects and i would give for
example
your transport issue with task and
finish group to look at the
issues and then to decide whether they
can make recommendations to both
committees
as to how to take it forward on a wider
scale
it is a big question i believe you think
you'll find
you'll have to agree that but the task
and finish group from overview and
scrutiny might be a good starting point
and a number of members maybe two from
each council
could could be involved in setting that
up so i'd just like to suggest that
an increase of use of task and finish
groups um
of this of this of these committees
as a recommendation and i'd happily
propose that if i can find a second
councillor okay that's fine so there we
have five
recommendations does anybody want to add
any others
okay so those five recommendations would
be carried forward
and we'll be voting on those
individually um
we're missing what
mclaren proposing and i believe it was
councillor grand and seconding
as i recall
councillors
sorry
is that okay yeah we've got that it's
fine
so we have proposers and seconders for
five recommendations we will
we can if you wish members vote upon
those all on block
one to five i believe that's perfectly
okay in governance procedures so
uh that's what i propose we do all five
of those recommendations to be made to
wherever they should be made
to so if the voting is
open yes chair the uh voting is now in
progress
if you go to your modern.gov app
for the agenda and press the plus sign
at the top
scroll down your gender the blue line
indicates the vote in progress
thanks very much
also in favor
sorry chan that is unanimous
thank you very much members that's uh
unanimous
and we'll now move on then to item eight
um the forthcoming
decision list do members have any
comments on the current
forthcoming decision list
this is the noting only and then items 9
and 10 are the babra and mid-suffolk
overview and scrutiny work plans
um a good point at which to make
suggestions
for noting for the chairs to consider
and as they go through as you will see
these are appendix
a
i'm looking at the mid suffolk one at
the moment so you can see that
our review today is in there in june um
we have the sifko business plan and some
information on public realm
in july the annual review of the joint
homes and housing strategy and
homelessness and rough
sleeping reduction strategy and a
customer service
update there are gaps from august
onwards which
obviously will be filled in the course
of the year
but uh if any of them has any ideas
right now
we can note them for future reference
and they can be brought
brought towards the uh for the chairs to
consider
i think we can do it for both councils
and i believe we should okay we just
know which one is for which and if
it applies to both councils then we can
apply it to both councils it's up to the
chairs to work that out
thank you chair i've got two two
suggestions to look at
one is that we look at um i'm not quite
sure how to
word it either delivery of services to
the rural areas
or rural transport i think the former
would
take in a lot more that would be a lot
more work
so i think that's something for us
perhaps to talk with officers about
we don't want to give them such a such a
broad topic that we gain nothing from it
so that would be one
and the other is a scrutiny of the
infrastructure delivery plan
okay fine so those could be added on to
the potential i'm subject
for the drink counselor carter you have
a suggestion
oh thank you for turning my bike on
whoever did that
um i'd suggest whilst looking at to
rural transport
to include as well accessibility and
interconnectivity not everyone's going
to
want to get a train or a bus but to be
able to walk from one town to another or
to be able to cycle
or use a wheelchair to get another place
but so
it's all one it's all interconnected
so if we could look at absolutely
interconnectivity i think
i mean when this is scoped and i suspect
it will have to be scoped i think the
size of the scoping will just
show what a large and huge subject it is
i recall um i can't remember who it was
it was made transport joined up
transports uh many years ago in a
government um um nothing really came of
it
they've always been they've always
talked about integrating transport but
we'll see how if anything comes with it
but i think it's got to be done on a
local basis first
councillor welland and then councillor
scarf yeah i just would i think we'd
perhaps have to drop the word rural
because i
i mean and what uh carter said reminds
me that
there are also problems um traveling in
and around
uh stone market and there possibly is
similar problems
some people would regard stone market as
rural but i think
this is the problem it's it's
i was being cheeky nothing more than
that all right
effectively what it is is that it's our
districts that matter here and
regardless
of what we call the communities they are
our communities so
not a problem um councillor brandon
if sorry council scarf you're next i'll
come back to you councillor brandon
thank you um one item that's on both of
our lists is the underspender grants for
bringing empty homes back into use and
we did look at that
in march and and we determined whilst we
were in the emergency response
um senior leadership team deemed this
was not a high priority i wonder if we
can have another look at that
again because uh housing is
is an ongoing issue as we all know and
actually
the urgency of ensuring that empty homes
are back into use
is more pressing now than ever before
particularly with the fact that doing
the pandemic um
tenants have had considerable protection
uh from
from from the government um
in in terms of not being able to be
evicted etcetera but i think it's going
to become a very live issue and
therefore any empty homes
that could be put to good use i think
you know that that should be further up
the agenda now
yep i think that's about to become a
topic in both councils is it not
i recall there's some work due to come
forward in the next few months
i could be wrong is my right kathy
bringing empty homes back into use
underspended the grants
because of the covid situation uh this
was sort of put on the back burner
um it was
slt deemed it not to be a high priority
in the emergency but i
believe that we're hopefully in coming
to the end of the emergency
there's certainly work ongoing and in
that and
um it would be an area that you could
add to your list for consideration
um this year but with the benefit of
further input from
gavin fisk um well i saw
i saw some figures recently about a
number of homes that were not in use
recently and i
concur with you there anybody else
yes councillor grant and i apologize
back to you now
that's right sherman um thank you um
i really should do this so please
forgive me
but when it comes to examining
something like transport which is
a county issue
what what are we expecting to come out
of it and will we
be perhaps bringing
the transport people from county in as
our witnesses
and how i know that's going to be for
the scoping nearer the time but i'm just
wondering
as this isn't a a district issue
can we what are we hoping to achieve we
are able to do so
we can call for witnesses from county
council and we can call witnesses from a
bus company if we want to
we can call witnesses from all sorts of
places if we want to
um and some of them we can actually
summons if we want to can't we i'm not
sure we have summonsed anybody
but you know we can sort of we we have
powers council scarf
thank you chair um well i'm just going
to give an example that's particularly
on
rural transport when i was previously a
member of the district council
some years ago when scrutiny started as
a process in fact
very new to the process we actually
called in uh the county council when
they
changed the number of subsidies to
public uh
bus services and we actually had expert
witnesses
as well who were directly affected by
those changes in the services so we
actually conducted a review and i think
this must
be eight 10 10
12 years ago so we've done it before and
there's absolutely no reason
there was a natural reticence at that
time by the other authorities to come
and present to us but we reminded them
that they actually have a duty to do so
because
if it affects either of these two
councils
residents we can review it exactly how
you said
so i think we should do it most
definitely on the citizens advice
bureau task and finish group we had a
full range of witnesses from suffolk
ipswich and all authorities involved
um so yes all possible it just
needs the will
okay well we sorry
i think we've added enough to the work
plan for the moment council casting you
have something to add
thank you very much um mr chairman i i
did wonder if with this census
been that's recently been completed
whether that's something that we
should have we should be looking in
there
because this goes quite a long way um
into next year whether that's something
that we need to look at the
comparison how mid suffolk and babur are
changing
i'm not sure when the results are due
but i have a strong suspicion it's not
going to be 2022.
is it gonna be 2022 they'll be out
within a year okay
okay well there might be one for the
future then i think so and
march 22 and obviously the the effect of
any census is well
it's basically a massive um snapshot of
your demographics
and uh you're not going to get a better
one really are you
yeah okay council brandon
i don't know if it's um unpossible to
examine this
but um i was wondering whether we're
allowed or able to look at the way
the cabinet or cabinets are operating
and see whether it's working for the
whole of the council
emily can you answer this is a sort of
governance question i suspect and of
course the
decision about the cabinet system um
is is is something that
whether um some of the details of it are
working you know whether it's working
communications wise and
the way it kind of operates as a
practical cis
uh you know in a practical way for the
whole of council
are we are we learning information we
need
or is it are certain aspects of it
working
for them and for us you know is that
something we're able to
scrutinize yes jeff if through you if i
can answer that
and yeah absolutely the you know one of
the primary
functions of the overview and scrutiny
committee is to hold the cabinet to
account
and to look at the way that the cabinet
functions and that doesn't need to be
restricted solely to looking at
the decisions that have been made by the
cabinet you can also look at the wider
context in which the cabinet operates so
are individual portfolio holders
effectively
working within their portfolio are they
communicating the key aspects of that
portfolio
um does is is the cabinet meeting itself
open
enough you know is there enough
transparency all of those aspects so
not just actually the outcomes um from
the activity of the the cabinet but
actually how it operates it's in itself
is is
within the scope of the committee one
thing we've always stressed
since we instituted the cabinet system
at baber and
and mid suffolk is the the relationship
between council cabinet and scrutiny
and that the three sort of legs on which
the council operates and if they don't
communicate with each other
that's a problem so yes fine good point
yeah sorry now i'm making another
suggestion then please
that um that we'd look at doing that
but then maybe make it more than one
meeting
so that we look at one aspect of it
or a you know certain aspects of it in
one meeting but i think it's
almost like a two big topic and that
maybe
another set of aspects in in another
meeting
would it be something to scope and then
just i think that's
what you're describing here sounds to me
like yes a scoping process i think
probably yeah and then that would give
officers a in and then you could take it
from the scoping
yes coverage and how you wish to go
further and
drill down to because i suspect you
won't change everything in every
single aspect of a big subject like that
but if you get some bits of it
right yeah then rest may follow but it
is a big subject
as you say so i think we may find that
it may
require more than one meeting to tackle
it
and to do it well enough absolutely i
think it perhaps ought to be something
that we should do
earlier rather than later because it's
going to take a while or at least to
look at earlier rather than because it's
going to take a while
and then we would hope to see the
results of any meeting
within this term rather than pushing to
the long grass or
you know it all take too long for it to
[Music]
for the effects to be seen in our time
in this term
so now i guess that becomes as
a priority perhaps
if everyone agrees sorry from what
you're saying then
i mean looking at that in terms of
the spaces in the um the work plans
i've got the mid-suffolk one there but i
think the paper one is going to be very
similar
august would be the earliest in the sort
of gap in the calendar
i mean i just suggest just i'm just
suggesting
well july is is taken up 15th of july
august is the earliest opportunity and
then there's september
emily and chair just
in terms of timetabling i think it would
be useful to give yourselves a bit
longer just to think about the format of
that review
and particularly because i think this is
a very good opportunity
for scrutiny to co-design the review
with members of the cabinet because of
course that is something that
you can do is you can look at those
issues together and the
cabinet themselves will of course be
reflecting on their
operation the way they work the way they
interact with other councillors
and i'm sure they have some suggestions
that they'd like the committee to look
into as well so
i think giving it a bit longer in terms
of your program actually enables you to
have those conversations with the
leaders and other members of the cabinet
when you're forming the scope of the
review off the cuff
i would say that it should be a
collaborative process if it's to be of
any use
so that it shouldn't be adversarial
between scrutiny and cabinet it should
be
cooperative and forth and and and
beneficial and obviously beneficial to
the whole of the council
that would be the principle you'd want
to run on i hope
so uh that can be added to the work plan
council mclaren
presumably we are talking about
individual groups
this is not a joint i guess you would
have to say that it would be
mid-suffolk and doing it in one group
and they paper in another possibly
they're not because they are dissimilar
they are dissimilar cabinets and the
and the similar makeups um operate
against does that be
perfectly reasonable would it not so
this is quite possible that the two
separate
councils could examine the scrutinize
that aspect separately and should
probably work with their own cabinets
they are that we know there are
differences so let's
let's um embrace that and work with it
okay um any more
items that people wish to add to the
work plans henriette
oh sorry kathy just reflecting on the
fact that we are hopefully coming out of
a pandemic
and and thinking about what the key
issues and impacts
um on our communities are as a result of
that i'm just thinking about those areas
like mental health
and skills debt and and those would
again
be very much themes in the if you like
the system theme
how are the system of partners um
working effectively to address
um those sort of increased impacts on
communities
seems a little obvious that we never
thought of mentioning the kovid
coming out of the pandemic and the
recovery process obviously it's going to
be a topic on everybody's minds
so that might be something that
definitely i think it'll still be a
little while before we'll get
true clarity in um and
facts and figures but i think it's got
to be added to the list
catholic carter
thank you again who is it who is doing
that for me um
um i did wonder whilst scrutinizing off
cabinets would it not be beneficial if
we scrutinize each other to give carrot
because whilst we are crucified in our
own cabinet there might be political
bias there might be some
within it might make difficult and if
you're looking at another
outside and you're looking from an
external point
would that not be beneficial to have an
outside perspective as well as an
internal
perspective i can foresee governance
issues with that
but um what do other members think of
particularly what does emily think
thank you chair so you would have to
vote
on any recommendations separately
because obviously this is a
sovereign council issue it's about how
the cabinet for that particular council
functions
but there is no restriction on you
having perhaps some of those
early parts of that discussion and that
review together
recognizing as members have said today
the benefits of having
more voices in the room and a greater
depth of experience
so you would you'd need to take any
recommendations separately but the
the work in the lead up to that could be
done jointly you'd be establishing
general principles but perhaps applying
them differently
in terms of decisions made by or
recommendations made by
each separate committee
i think is how you handle that but it is
an interesting one thank you very much
that's
the sort of meat and drink to emily
isn't it
but i like it right sorry um
i'm getting off the point shall we move
on i think we've got everything we can
add at the moment we've got coved in
there
and does anybody have anything they want
to add before we
well conclude the meeting effectively
thanks to everybody for coming today
reasonable amount of time we've got
through a lot of ground i don't think
we'd have done it as quickly otherwise
the next joint overview and scrutiny
committee meeting
will be on monday the 28th of june
at 9 30 a.m i would recommend that there
would
i would hope that there will be a
pre-meeting to nine o'clock
but of course that's entirely up to uh
the chairs
um can i thank everybody today and uh
good luck at the mid-suffolk annual
council tonight
and the weber amidst baybrook annual
council
tomorrow night
you